all right thank you mercedes when it
comes to weight loss dr nash
she has the solution take a look at
becky's results
i lost 42 pounds on dr nash's program
i'm seven pounds away from my goal if i
can do this i can do anything
dr nash what blows me away about becky
is one is her weight loss
but two she has this sense of happiness
about her now i love becky's results
i do too um becky was an amazing client
because she was referred from somebody
else
she's school teacher and one of the moms
saw that she was
frustrated and upset she was literally
crying because she couldn't lose the
weight
and while she's while my one patient is
cradling her she's calling the phone to
talk to me so yeah
all the stories are always amazing they
truly are and today we're going to
talk about stubborn fat and getting rid
of that stubborn fat and
why is it so hard for people to lose
weight that stubborn fat
around their belly and around their
thighs yeah like that's where we always
see it right
guys see it mainly in the belly women
see it in the belly button thighs and
what people don't really know is that
the reason it's stubborn there
is because there's a problem under the
surface that's
driving that weight issue and unless you
fix that problem
that's always going to be a stubborn
area that won't go away or will come
back easily
so what are the three issues that that
your program solves or three of the
biggest issues that your program solves
yeah so when we talk about things like
stubborn belly fat there's usually three
things that can be going on the first
one
is you have a dietary hormone problem
where you're not burning
body fat 70 to 75 percent of the time
like you should
second one is you could have something
called fatty liver
disease which makes it almost impossible
for you to burn body fat properly
and then the final one is inflammation
literally meaning that your organs are
on fire
and when that happens your body soaks up
belly fat to soothe the organs so again
if this is going on you can eat less and
move more all you want but it's going to
be stubborn
so when it comes to your your patients
your clients what's the typical weight
loss what would someone expect when it
comes to weight loss how much do they
expect to lose
sure so a standard weight loss program
that we do commercially might be one or
two pounds a week
my programs tend to get three to seven
pounds a week on average and then we
show you that your body's going to hold
that weight loss by making you eat up to
3 000 calories a day
and i do want to touch on you because
you're such a great success story uh
tell everyone how much
weight you lost and how long ago was
this sure
i'm somebody that started gaining weight
when i was eight years old i struggled
with it for about 25 years looking for
an
answer when i finally figured out these
issues for myself i lost 80 pounds
got back down to my normal weight and
that's like 12 or 13 years ago and now
it's my job to help other people get
into their next chapter and you're doing
you're helping people all across the
valley and and i love you for that and
every time you come on the show you
bring a special
what do you have for us today actually
so what i have is
if you were to come and see me face to
face or even online find me in another
way
it's normally 97 to do that evaluation
because you're setting up a teleseminar
with a doctor
but if you mention that you saw me on
las vegas now we have 10 spots
available for less than 10. 90 off to
find out if
this is a problem that's going on with
you and to get the answer so you can
solve it